いやあどうもこんにちははじめしゃちょー
です今ここ
誰もいない取材室にいるわけなんです
けれども
皆さんアバターってご存知でしょうか
もちろん見たことある人いると思います僕
ももう34回ぐらい見てるんですけれども
見たことない人が多分聞いたことだったり
あのわかると思うんですよあの青い方々
です青い方々のアバターという映画がある
んですけれども今からですね僕の後輩とか
仲間を呼んで1作目のアバターを一緒に
見るんですけれどもただ見るわけではあり
ませんどうぞ
[音楽]
座っていただいて今回アバターっぽい方々
を準備しました
[音楽]
はいというわけでですねアバターの映画
最初見たら
青い方々ちょっと怖かったに謎だと思うん
ですよねああ俺のネックレス僕の後輩には
アバター見てないやつもいると思うので
突然
映画館で
両隣がアバターになった
映画を見てる時に
両隣がアバダーっぽい人たちになってい
たらどうなってしまうのかちょっと
リアクション見てみたいと思います
相当可愛いと思うんでちょっと実際にやっ
てみたいと思います
狭いいってみましょう
[音楽]
DC当たるですね
というわけでアバターの人に来てもらい
ましたー
アバター見たことありますか
ワンは見ましたあーいいですねはいもう
すぐ次の新作が出るということで
結構前に出たので記憶が曖昧だと思うので
1回見直しましょうおー
話はまずはそこからだ
大丈夫かな
治るかな大丈夫まだ
全然序盤の序盤では大丈夫始まって20秒
ぐらい
[音楽]
[拍手]
触ってみればナビの人なので
力強い
気をつけろ
[音楽]
おはようございますおはようございます
というわけで400はいなんと
我々
アバターの新作
ウォーターというのがあるんですけども
なんと
アバターサダーでございます
アバターサラ
新作を普及するみたいなおー
すごいよく見たことありますありますどう
でした
面白かったですけど忘れましたねそうです
結構
前に出てるんで過去の記憶とかも色々ある
と思う1回見直すとおさらいしましょう
まずわかりました話はそこからですはい
やめていきましょう
[音楽]
面白かったですかいや面白かったです
なんか
未来
地球がたどる可能性のある
話としてね
十分ありえそうで多分地球が多分ピンチな
んでしょうねもう資源がなくて
確かに未来の話もね未来の話で
じゃあ電気お願いします
[音楽]
お疲れ様ですお疲れ様です
出てるねー
さんはいあなたアバターという映画見た
ことありますか
うわぁないです見ようはいいやーイケメン
と見る映画楽しみだなあ
俺もハンサムと見る
映画楽しみですね
殺す
[音楽]
見てくるねはい
電気戻りますかね
[音楽]
うわっ
ちょっと待って
くださいね大丈夫ですか大丈夫大丈夫
本当に無理
本当に
本当にごめんなさいパジャマさん座って
くださいよ
失礼します何で何も起きない悪い人
と確かに俺がビビってだけかもしれない
えちょっと俺座りますね
失礼します
しっかりそれで1回
本当に
ごめんなさい
はいというわけで今回はですね12月の
16日に劇場公開されるアバターway
ofwaterにちなんだ企画をやってみ
ましたはいやっぱ
みんなねこうリアクションが様々でしたね
もうナビのことを知っているからすると
優しい人もいるしっていうのはわかると
思うんですけどもサーブとか知らなかった
んで
知らなかったやっぱりこう隣にいると
びっくりしたのかなと思いましたで今回の
アバターwayofwaterなんです
けれども
映像のクオリティがとにかくすごいという
ことですもう没入型というかこの映像体験
がすごいらしいので
気になってますね僕もまた見てないのです
すぐ見に行きたいと思っておりますそして
今回のアバターさらにすごいのが若者の
共感を呼ぶ子供世帯を含む家族の
愛と絆の物語となっています
前作はですね家族というより愛とか濃いっ
て言った感じの内容があったんですけれど
も本作はなんと美しく真っ青なパンドラの
海を舞台に家族というテーマで描かれて
いるみたいでございますさらに感動する
ことを間違いなしです
皆さんアバター待望の13年ぶりの新作
です13年前って思わないけど僕めっちゃ
記憶に鮮明にあるので皆さんぜひ見に行っ
てみてくださいじゃあ
[音楽]